Speaker 1: . All right, let's get into this
week's mailbag. You can write in info at David
Pakman dot com. I should say after the deluge
and some angry emails last week, the number of
emails we get far exceeds the five to 10 that I
can look at during the mailbag segment. We get
a few hundred emails every day. Multiply that
by seven days a week. You can quickly see
why we can't get to all of them. So info at David
Pakman dot com, but emailing is no guarantee
that your email will make it into the mailbag.
Let's start with today's first emails from Chris.
Chris says Hey David, hope you're well. What if
Democrats are left leaning? People started up a
faux right wing party in order to steal votes from
the Republicans. It might be hard to pull off the
lie to make it seem authentic, but politics is a
dirty game. After all, if they could divert votes,
then mission accomplished. If they actually win,
then mission accomplished. Just something I was
musing over for a bit of fun. You know, I'm not
totally sure that that's legal. There was this
case, actually. I think it involved. I think it's
still going on. It involves Matt Gaetz in Florida
about the idea of him being involved in supporting
like a sort of diversion candidate. And this is
exactly the idea that Chris is pointing out.
I think that there some legal issue with it,
actually, although I don't remember exactly what
it is. I don't really have a moral problem with it
in its sort of traditional sense, but I question
whether it would really work. And at the end of
the day, obviously, if it's against the law, then
it shouldn't be done. But even if it's not, I'm
just not sure that a fake right wing party. Would
really work other than maybe in a few districts,
but I'd be willing to think about the logistics
a little more, and maybe I'd have my mind changed
on that. Kevin Roden. Kevin says this is a
video clip that aired on CBS Morning News
a month ago. The story is about the debate on
requiring children to wear masks in school or not.
At 2:34 into the video, a frustrated parent says
to the school board Science is not fact. Science
is meant to be challenged. Keep up the great
work, David. Enjoy your YouTube channel! Here's
this is this is actually a very interesting topic.
Increasingly, you hear from people on the right
things like science has been wrong. And you
have to be allowed to challenge science.
Both of those statements are true. But you've
got to challenge science with science and
contrary to like this is what makes
science different than religious beliefs
in most organized religion as well as in cults.
You're not rewarded for challenging the orthodoxy
and the teachings of the pastor cult leader,
whatever science, on the other hand. First of all,
has a self-correcting mechanism where hopefully
we can duplicate results. We do more studies.
And there's also pretty big financial and fame
rewards if you were able to disprove some major
accepted theory in science. But you've got to do
it. Sorry, as I hit my Mike, you've got to do it
with science. And so simply coming in and saying,
Well, I challenge the science of vaccines with my
opinion that they do this or that they do that,
or my pastor's feeling that they do this and that
it's absolutely true that science is meant to
be challenged. The scientific method includes
such a framework for those challenges. But that
doesn't mean anyone's opinion is just as valid
of a challenge or alternative to the accepted
scientific view. So often with these people,
there's like this kernel of truth. But it's
completely misunderstood and misapplied.
More people continue to write in about the Trump
flu pandemic thing 1917 flu, 1918 flu, as many
of you know, Donald Trump started saying the 1917
flu, even though it's 1918, and he kept saying it.
Some people said, Oh no. He's saying 17, because
17 is the 17th letter in the alphabet. I'm sorry.
Q is the 17th letter in the alphabet. It's
a signal to Q and on a t wrote in and has a
different idea and says, Sir, your 1918 1917 flu
analysis being a product of Trump's narcissism got
me laughing. That's my theory on why Trump eats
well-done steaks with ketchup. When asked, Sir,
how would you like it cooked? Would you like
it? Rare, medium, well-done? Trump answered,
Not understanding the question. Of course I want
it. Well done, like correctly done. And that same
narcissism prevented him from sending his dry
steak back to partially remedy his predicament.
He used ketchup because it was there. When
asked why, he declared It's how he always eats
his steak. I wish this were true, but the simpler
explanation? Maybe a burnt steak with ketchup most
resembles his favorite hamburgers. Anyhow, thanks
for bringing some sanity to the world. Appreciate
what you do. Yeah, I think there's a lot to that.
Not that this is like the most important issue,
but I do think often with Trump, it's like when
he started saying plasma instead of plasma, and
maybe someone went to him and said it's plasma.
And he was like, No, no, no, no, no. I say plasma.
Maybe nobody did. And he has no awareness that
he may be saying something wrong, but I think
that the narcissism is a more likely thing than
it's a signal to Q. He called it the 1917 flu.
Maybe someone corrected him, or he certainly
must have seen it on the news, but he decided
now I call it the 1917 flu. I think that that's
a very plausible scenario. Next email today
is from Chris Chris. This is very interesting,
Chris says. David, I live in Texas and I identify
as a Republican, but frankly, I'm embarrassed
to be one at this point in time. It seems a
large number of Republicans currently in office
don't live in reality. I believe as long as our
lawmakers have the US vs. them mindset, they will
never come together for the good of the people.
It is time for the American people to get off the
couch and vote to remove these stagnant lawmakers
and replace them with individuals who will put
the people first. Is it time to form a common
sense party? I enjoy the show and appreciate
you shining a light on things, no matter what
side of the fence they are on. Listen, I have no
problem with the idea. The idea of a common sense
party has been floated many times before. To some
degree, I think it's kind of what Andrew Yang is
trying to do with the forward party. Andrew sent
me his book and we're trying to get him on the
show for an interview soon. But often what you end
up with in these situations is that there will be
some seemingly reasonable people from the right,
like Chris, who might be good faith participants
in such a common sense party. But very quickly,
you realize the vast majority of those people
don't really have any common sense, and you
can't really involve them because their ideas
are terrible and they're not willing to have their
minds changed. And so there's really no practical
way that you can include them. And that's what
we often end up sort of bumping up against for
lack of a better term. And so I love the idea. I
would love to be able to say, Hey, you know what,
if we keep the left? But then we include just like
the sane right, then on average will have a more
reasonable goal there. End up being we end up with
very few people like Chris, who we can actually
include. And then then what you end up risking
is it appeals to more Democrats than Republicans
and just hurts Democrats and leads to Republicans
being elected due to being a spoiler. And that's
a disaster that is not something I can like in
good faith, really support if it's going to even
further sink the country into the bad. So send me
your thoughts. I mean, it's it is my analysis too
negative, too pessimistic? Let me know, Elizabeth
wrote in about Americans refusing the COVID
vaccine for religious beliefs. Elizabeth says
David, hopefully you can clear this up for me.
I recently saw on the news a woman who was upset
because she was threatened to be removed from the
kidney transplant list because she refused to
get a COVID vaccine, stating religious belief.
What religion would prohibit vaccination would
allow an organ transplant. I believe this is
just an avenue people are using to stronghold
their refusal to get the COVID vaccine. Can
you shed light on this? Love listening to
your show? Thanks for what you do! Yeah,
I don't have a specific answer, but it's a it's a
good question, which is the religions that tend to
be just skeptical of medical. Like Christian,
science is one where I once knew someone who.
Worked with a Christian scientist who said,
listen, if I were to, like, get hurt or it
was a kind of a more dangerous job, you can't just
call an ambulance, you've got to call my pastor.
The pastor needs to first pray for me and
authorize what needs to happen, including
whether the ambulance can take me or whatever.
I guess I don't know, but it would seem to me
if an organization like that would have as
much of a problem with organ transplants
as much as the vaccine, or there
would be some kind of double standard.
I don't actually know are there religions where
an organ transplant is OK, but vaccination really
is not OK? I'm not aware of them. My instinct is
that Elizabeth is probably on to something here
and that so-called religious objections to
vaccination are often just ways to try to stop
conversation. It's sort of like, you know, the
right likes to say, when the left doesn't like
a conversation, they go, That's racist and
everybody goes, Oh, and gets scared and backs
away from the conversation. Similarly, I think
that my religion says I can't get vaccinated
could could be used similarly. Here's
another interesting vaccine question
this one's from Michael. Michael says, Hey,
David, when I hear all these anti-vax people
incorrectly scream about gene therapy, what
Michael is referring to is some people say
the mRNA vaccines aren't vaccines, they're gene
therapies. Michael says When I hear them scream
about that, I wonder what's wrong with gene
therapy? I'm not an expert on the subject, but
isn't gene therapy how we would eventually cure
such diseases as cancer, diabetes and dementia,
to name a few? I always thought of gene therapy as
the holy grail of medicine relating to longevity.
Just wanted to share that thought. Yeah, I mean,
listen, I'm not an expert on that. So I don't I
shouldn't really comment specifically, but this
reminds me of the entire the vaccine makes you
magnetic. It magnetize, as you do. We know
for sure that being magnetized is bad.
And what I mean by that is it's sort of a joke.
But have the anti-vaxxers who say the vaccine
magnetize is your arm or your whole body?
Have they said why it's bad to be magnetized?
Understanding the problems with metal implants
and MRI's, you know, we could we could imagine
some reasons. But the point is they don't really
ever say that. They just say, well, it it's it's
it's this and therefore it's assumed to be bad.
Is it bad if the vaccine worked via gene therapy?
Maybe that's OK, as long as it protects you
from serious COVID and that so very good. Very
good point. From Mike there. And then here's a
little bonus for you. This one's from YouTube.
This is just wild. Someone wrote to me
and they said, reread the FDA website
Idol approved for EU, not EU to EU or the word for
water in French emergency use authorized requiring
Madonna, JNJ, Pfizer, you paid opposition.
Remember, it's the anti-vaxxers getting paid,
not the people reporting the science. But I
did not know that the FDA was now by emergency
use requiring Madonna songs be played. I find
that extremely authoritarian. If people don't
like Madonna, they shouldn't be forced to listen
to Madonna. I think that that's absolutely,
absolutely horrible. Obviously, this
is just riddled with misspellings.
They met Madonna by Madonna. They meant UK
rather than EU. Oh, boy, oh boy, this is,
you know, there's there's two views about
something like this one is these are obviously
foreign trolls because the English is such a
disaster. The other side of it is, unfortunately,
there are people who write adults who write like
this in the United States, and that is a really,
really sad commentary on the state of education in
the United States. And I don't mean teachers are
bad, but just the ability of your average person.
I mean, this is. Is this considered partial
illiteracy? Is this so bad that we actually
this is this is a sort of. Partial illiteracy,
if someone writes like this, I don't know. I
don't know, but it's certainly very, very scary.
You can write to me info at David Pakman dot com.
Remember, just writing to me doesn't guarantee
that your email will be chosen, but it is info at
David Pakman dot com. You can also sign up for the
bonus show an extra show every day at join Packman
dot com. Sign up today. It's a beautiful day.